Welcome back.
So we just figured out
how long does this
thing stay in the air.
So what can we do with that?
Let me clear all of this and
redraw it because maybe every
time I redraw it, it might
further clarify things.
Let me actually draw things a
little bit fancier this time.
So I have the ball and it's
moving-- look at that.
Let me just draw the triangle
ahead of time.
I'm going to use
fancy-- whoops.
Actually, let me use
a thicker line.
So this was the initial
vector.
Then I wanted to do--
switch to green.
This is its horizontal.
I'm going to draw the
arrows in a second.
I just want to get all the line
tool work out of the way.
Bam.
And this is the--
close enough.
And then, if I use my
paint tool, I could
draw an arrow there.
Switch back to green.
Draw an arrow there.
Switch back to magenta.
So this was 10 meters per second
at a 45 degree angle.
We figured out in the last
video that its horizontal
velocity is equal to
10 cosine of 45.
Which equals 5 square
root of 2.
And we also figured out that the
vertical velocity is equal
to 10 sine of 45 degrees.
Which also equals 5
square root of 2.
And we wanted to figure out, how
long does this thing stay
in the air?
And we said, well, if we're
going-- the vertical component
is 5 square root of 2
meters per second.
So if I'm going 5 square root
of 2 meters per second, the
ball-- how long does it take for
the ball to go from that
point to the point that
it's stationary at
the top of its path?
It's going at 5 square root
of 2 meters per second.
And then it goes to 0.
So how long does it take to
decelerate from 5 square
root of 2 to 0?
And there we just said, you
know, change in velocity.
Well my change in velocity is
minus 5 square root of 2.
That equals acceleration, which
is minus 10 meters per
second squared times time.
We figured out the time when the
ball leaves to kind of its
highest point is the square
root of 2 seconds.
And that happens if you just
solve this equation.
And that's how long the ball
takes to go from the ground to
its highest point.
And it's going to take the exact
amount of time for it to
reaccelerate and
come back down.
So it takes square root of 2
seconds to go up, it's going
to take square root of
2 seconds to go down.
So the total time is equal
to 2 square root of 2.
This is the total time.
This is kind of a nice
intermediate thing that we've
discovered.
Now, can we use this to
figure out how far
does that ball travel?
How far is this sucker
going to go?
Well, the entire time that--
you know, we were messing
around with the vertical speed
or the vertical velocity of
this ball and the vertical
acceleration, vertical position.
The whole time the ball was
going up and down, it was also
going to the right because it
has this horizontal velocity.
And we're going to assume
that the horizontal
velocity stays constant.
And why can we assume that?
Well one, we're assuming that
there's no air resistance.
Because air resistance makes
very-- things very
complicated.
If this is something like a
penny or a marble, it actually
does have very little
air resistance.
So air isn't going
to slow it down.
And so if there's no air, what
can slow it down in the
horizontal direction?
Well, nothing.
Gravity only acts downwards.
Gravity doesn't make something
slow down as it moves
horizontally.
You could imagine pushing
something on ice.
And if there's nothing slowing
it down, no friction, no air
resistance, it'll just
keep on going.
And actually, the assumptions
we're making would be
absolutely true on the moon.
Because the moon has no air.
But anyway, so the whole time
the ball's going up and down
it's also moving to the right
at this speed, at 5 square
root of 2 meters per second.
And let me ask you a question:
how long is it going to be
moving to the right?
Well, it's going to be moving
to the right as long as it's
up in the air.
And do we know how long it's
going to be up in the air?
Well yeah, we just
figured that out.
We figured out that it stays in
the air for 2 square root
of 2 seconds.
So to figure out its horizontal
distance, to figure
out how long it is along the
ground, so we could say change
in distance horizontally.
That just equals my average
velocity, which is just this
because it doesn't
really change.
So it equals 5 square root
of 2 meters per second.
Times the time that
I'm in the air.
Times 2 square root
of 2 seconds.
Times this sucker.
2 square root of 2 seconds.
So when you multiply
it out-- let's see.
10 times-- square root of
2 times square root of
2 is 2 times 2.
So we go 20 meters.
That I think is pretty cool.
All I did is I said well I'm
throwing something at 10
meters per second at
a 45 degree angle,
how far did it go?
And you could figure it out.
You could figure out that
it went 20 meters.
And actually, you could do
things the other way.
And I'll do that in future
problems. You can figure out
the exact angle you need to
throw something or you need to
shoot something, if we were
thinking military terms. If
you were an artillery man and
you had to arm the-- you had
to figure out what angle to
shoot the big gun at to shoot
a target-- I don't know, 5
miles away-- not that I
advocate these type of things--
war is very bad.
You would be doing essentially
this problem.
I don't know if people
in the military are
actually doing it.
They're probably having a
computer do it for them.
But it's really not
that hard to do.
And you know, if we ever lose
our computers and we have to
do things with bows and arrows,
it's good to be able
to sit down and do the
math like this.
So that's all I'm going to do
for-- well, we could do a
couple of other things too.
We can also figure out how
high the ball went.
And how high the ball went is
actually no different than the
1-dimensional problem.
We know that this is the
initial velocity
in its upward direction.
We know it goes to 0.
So its average velocity in
the upward direction
is going to be what?
Its average velocity in the
upward direction is going to
be this plus this
divided by 2.
So the average horizontal
velocity--
vertical velocity, sorry.
Vertical velocity average.
This is funny notation.
Is just going to be
half of this.
It's going to be 5 square
root of 2 over 2.
And it travels that
for how long?
Well just while it's going up,
it travels that for a square
root of 2 seconds times the
square root of 2 seconds.
Distance is the average
velocity times time.
So this is a sequel.
This square root of 2 times this
square root of 2 is 2,
and it cancels out with this.
So the peak height that we could
say, the height is going
to be 5 meters.
So that's pretty neat.
If I throw something at 10
meters per second at a 45
degree angle, its maximum height
is going to be 5 meters
and it's going to
go 20 meters.
So I could draw that.
Image, clear image.
Image, invert colors.
So let me draw my ground.
Oh, whoops.
So I'm going to draw my ground,
it's kind of a yellow
ochre ground.
And I'm going to shoot something
at an angle of 45
degrees at 10 meters
per second.
And we figured out that it
will go 20 meters and its
maximum height is going
to be-- let's see.
This is 10, so I'm
trying to draw
something kind of to scale.
So its maximum height
is roughly 5 meters.
It is exactly 5 meters.
Roughly is what I'm drawing.
And so its path is going to
look something like this.
You know, right from the get-go
it's at that angle, but
the angle is going to get
shallower and shallower.
Then it gets to 5 meters
and it comes down.
And then it hits the ground.
So there you go.
We just figured out how far
does that thing go and how
high does it go.
What else could you want?
So in the next video I'm going
to do this more generally, so
that we can kind of-- we
can work backwards.
If we know how far something
went and how long it was in
the air, maybe we could
figure out its angle.
Or maybe we could actually
figure out what the optimal
angle is to throw something
for distance.
I'll see you in the
next video.